oh  I don't know  all right good shot Corbin  yeah  oh no  wow  [Applause]  [Music]  okay here we go anywhere  [Applause]  one more round of applause everybody for  team spirit congratulations  and congratulations  this is such a great event and we're so  happy after three years to resume it  because we get to bring the kids from  our community into the airport teach  them a lot about the airport a bit about  Aviation but just to have fun and and  partner with the kids from the Boys and  Girls Club it is just really exciting  a lot of times this is the first time  they've ever been to the airport so  again it's getting them out in their  community and and seeing what's here  also it's it's a little job exposure too  so we want them to see where employment  and jobs are so that they can start to  look in and think about where they want  their features to be  and then just a little bit about the  mission  [Music]